continuamos con el estudio del planeta
lubri con 6 ahora algo que no te dije en
el último vídeo es que en realidad lubri
con 6 no está rotando en lo absoluto no
está rotando
no está rotando y esto es algo muy
importante es muy importante porque
debido a ello no podemos hablar de un
ecuador pero más bien deberíamos decir
que nuestro calcetín congelado viaja a
lo largo de un círculo máximo por
ejemplo este no sería un círculo máximo
porque hay todavía unos más grandes de
hecho este sería uno de los máximos ok
entonces nuestro calcetín viaja a lo
largo de un círculo máximo y por ejemplo
en la tierra del ecuador justamente es
uno de esos círculos máximos que son de
de diámetro o de longitud máxima pero
para hablar de ecuador debe estar
rotando nuestro nuestro planeta
suponiendo que es una esfera perfecta
ahora vamos a plantearnos otro
experimento mental digamos que en
nuestro calcetín no es el único objeto
que se encuentra en el planeta lúbrico
sino que además de todo hay aquí
/ amarillo que de hecho si le hacemos un
zoom si nos acercamos podemos ver que es
un plátano congelado no sé por qué hay
un plátano congelado es una buena
pregunta pero el punto es que hay un
plátano congelado pero con respecto al
centro de la con respecto al centro de
del louvre y con este plátano congelado
está completamente en reposo es decir no
se está moviendo en lo absoluto ok
entonces este plátano congelado no
acelera está en reposo
además el planeta no está rotando ok
entonces la pregunta es la siguiente
cuáles son las fuerzas que interactúan
con este plátano muy bien entonces
piensa cuáles deben ser y cómo se
comportan
entonces suponiendo que ya hiciste una
reflexión al respecto podemos ver que si
no se está moviendo entonces solo puede
haber dos tipos de fuerzas primero es la
fuerza de gravedad que también éste es
de la misma de la misma forma que en el
caso del calcetín verdad y sonsón es una
fuerza radial en el sentido de que se
dirige hacia el centro del planeta
verdad entonces aquí tenemos nuestra
fuerza de gravedad por otro lado tenemos
la fuerza normal la fuerza normal es
aquella fuerza que le imprime la
superficie
debido al contacto a esta a nuestro
plátano congelado muy bien entonces
déjame ponerlo con otro color para
distinguirlo
vamos a ponerlo con rojo
digamos que esta es la fuerza normal y
lo que sabemos es que para que esté en
reposo este objeto entonces la fuerza
normal la fuerza normal se debe cancelar
con la fuerza de gravedad es decir si
nosotros sumamos estas dos fuerzas nos
debe dar exactamente cero ok entonces ya
que para él para este caso del calcetín
si se cancelan estas fuerzas ahora
vuelvan nos perdón para el caso del
plátano si se cancelan las fuerzas en
realidad quiero volver al caso del
calcetín porque dejamos pendiente la
pregunta de decir realmente podían ser
tan iguales estas estas dos fuerzas y
vamos a dar una respuesta al respecto
ok recordemos que nuestro calcetín otra
vez viajaba sobre el louvre y con seis
que estaba hecho de lubrizol y evitaba
todo él toda la fricción se movía a un
kilómetro por hora constante orbitando a
lo largo de este círculo máximo en lubri
con seis
digamos que estaba orbitando a una
altura cero es decir al ras del suelo y
bueno con todas las hipótesis que hemos
dado la pregunta es exactamente la misma
como son las fuerzas normales o más bien
la fuerza normal y la fuerza de gravedad
con respecto a la otra que piensa si son
iguales o si pueden ser distintas
entonces suponiendo que ya meditas te un
poco al respecto vamos a ver qué pasaría
si estos fueran si estas dos fuerzas se
anularán se cancelarán estuvieran
balanceadas si yo tuviera que la fuerza
normal al sumar la con la fuerza de
gravedad
se anularán qué es lo que estaría
pasando bueno digamos que que nuestro
calcetín digamos que estuviera por aquí
en algún momento sale y que a lo mejor
se mueve en esta digamos de esta forma
aunque que estuviera orbitando justo con
el perímetro de esta figura que yo pinté
entonces si estas dos fuerzas se
anularán entonces no habría fuerza
alguna es decir la fuerza neta que actúa
sobre nuestro calcetín es cero y lo que
sabemos es que si no hay una fuerza
actuando sobre un cuerpo este tenderá a
seguir su movimiento rectilíneo uniforme
entonces imagínate que éste se va
moviendo aquí y no hay fuerza entonces
el movimiento rectilíneo uniforme sería
justamente de este estilo sería
tangencial a nuestro planeta y eso
significaría que el calcetín
eventualmente se saldría de nuestro
planeta literalmente por la tangente ok
entonces en realidad como tenemos un
movimiento circular
un poco digamos tenemos este movimiento
circular
digamos que hacemos un corte del
movimiento que está realizando nuestro
calcetín que aunque aquí no se ve muy
claro este es un movimiento circular lo
que sí sabemos es que en cada momento
hay una fuerza de atracción hacia el
centro verdad que es la fuerza de
gravedad en todos lados está esta fuerza
de atracción hacia el centro
en todos estos lados entonces como
nuestro calcetín está orbitando a una
altura cero quiere decir que por un lado
acelera hacia adentro y esa aceleración
es centrípeta si si hubiera si la fuerza
normal se digamos se anulará con la
fuerza de gravedad entonces pasaría esto
quiere decir que para no salirse para no
salirse por la tangente debe ser que la
fuerza de gravedad debe ser mucho más
bueno debe ser más grande que la fuerza
normal porque de lo contrario puede el
calcetín saldría fuera de nuestro
planeta entonces lo que ocurre es que la
magnitud de la fuerza de gravedad la
magnitud de la fuerza de gravedad es
mayor que la magnitud de la fuerza
normal
es mayor que la fuerza normal y esto es
porque debe haber una fuerza que empuje
hacia adentro verdad de otra forma se
saldría de nuestro planeta entonces no
tenemos la situación en donde las
fuerzas digamos se balancean sino que
tenemos una fuerza centrípeta neta la
magnitud de la fuerza de gravedad debe
ser mayor que la magnitud de la fuerza
normal ahora algo interesante que te
dejo para pensar y que quizás veamos en
algún otro tutorial es qué pasa si la
velocidad o más bien cis si si el
calcetín va acelerando más y más y cada
vez más y se va moviendo cada vez más
rápido cuál sería la relación con cómo
cambiaría esta relación en esta
situación en donde va acelerando te lo
dejo ahí para que lo pienses